fox news alert russian forces closing in
on kiev as officials fear the ukrainian
capital could fall as early as this
weekend so as the world watches moscow
shatter peace in europe the big question
remains has putin set his sights on
countries beyond ukraine let's bring in
fox news senior strategic analyst
retired four star general jack keane to
help us understand general always great
to speak with you before we look forward
in the future give me your perspective i
know you feel like
this hasn't gone exactly according to
plan for putin so give me your
perspective on the present how do you
think putin sits today stronger feeling
confident or weaker
well
well certainly um there are a number of
surprises here he selected the most
ambitious plan he could possibly select
and that's uh four axises of advance all
of them required their own logistics
support all of them requiring their own
air support the air campaign after the
first day it's obvious did not
did not go well excuse me
they left parts of the ukrainian air
force intact parks and their
infrastructure which was quite stunning
they weren't able to prepare
for their assault forces and in terms of
attacking ukrainian defensive positions
as effectively as they wanted so that's
why
uh the attack stalled in three three out
of the four of those axes uh which
certainly surprised most of us the
ukrainians really had i think a pretty
good day
i mean
it's obvious what's going to happen here
will i mean they they outmatch the
ukrainians but you you certainly got to
admire the ukrainians will here and the
steadfastness for them to fight for
their country and to fight for their
families right and their way of life
your heart your heart goes out to them
for sure
listen there's really challenges ahead
will here for putin he's going to topple
the government and move to some kind of
ukrainian pro-russian
uh government this was the same exact
government
that the people of ukraine threw out in
2014
hundreds of thousands of people
demonstrating against it and yanukovych
fled to russia
and that started the entire crisis of
2014 with the annexation of crimea and
moving them into eastern ukraine we're
about to go through a similar phase like
that again and it's not without its
challenges for vladimir putin here to
make this transition and to keep that
government in place despite the almost
overwhelming opposition to it by the
people of ukraine yeah i i asked you
whether or not he's stronger or weaker
today what i should have said is is this
fight tougher than anticipated for
vladimir putin and clearly your answer
is although it's inevitable he will
eventually win this short term
war
it's much tougher than he anticipated
and also tougher in the long term to
your point to
to pacify or control ukraine but looking
beyond that general what do you look uh
we're seeing jennifer griffin yesterday
reported there's some there's some troop
build up russian troop buildup on the
polish border everybody's concerned
about what could happen in the baltics
what he it's hard to climb inside his
mind but where does this go next what
are the ambitions of vladimir putin
i think we just listen to mr putin and
stop wishing away things i mean he he is
sad he's threatened the former soviet
republics that are now a part of nato
when he was justifying his operation on
ukraine
uh he he threatened those states
and uh he wants to bring them back into
his sphere of influence i think we take
that
seriously
and nato has to upgrade themselves in
terms of having an effective deterrence
on the ground not on paper with article
five i'm talking about troops on the
ground and the target has got to be the
baltics
and certainly poland but the baltics
primarily because they are
clearly the most vulnerable another
three of them lithuania is the most
vulnerable because it's got russia on
both sides
so yes
and
i'm familiar with a war game we played
just a couple of years ago as part of a
congressional commission and
russia took two of the capitals
in 60 hours and we had to fight our way
back into europe
because we're an ocean away in the
united states after them having taken
out our arrival airports on our arrival
airfields a major major challenge we
cannot take this for granted and i'm not
talking about a huge amount of u.s
troops here will that's not the right
answer we have a
we have a challenge with china and we're
outgunned and out man there and we have
to move resources in that direction this
is about the europeans right the
europeans sticking up for themselves the
german military is almost non-existence
in terms of its capabilities i'm being
so overly critical to make the point i
mean they and yet they have the largest
economy and there's other countries like
that that where there's not much
capability we have got to get serious
here in nato and up gun our capability
and our defense budgets are inadequate
will during the cold war
the defense budget averaged around seven
percent of gdp now it's it's south of
three
and it's inadequate to deal with the
threat in in europe that we're facing
and the threat in china that we're
facing and add to that the dimension of
what the iranians are about to do when
they get the jcpoa windfall money in a
few weeks as a result of a new deal
and what they're going to do at that
money to destabilize the middle east
right we have major strategic challenges
and we're inadequately funded general i
want to save a minute to follow up with
you about china but let me just follow
the conversation you just introduced so
that's fascinating you're asking the
europeans amassed troops in the baltics
as a physical deterrent to russia going
into lithuania latvia and estonia
not just american troops or not even
primarily american troops but european
troops to serve as a physical deterrent
and you mentioned your war games them
that you guys participated in a few
years ago taking the capitals of the
baltics in 60 hours i'm just curious
where did those war games play out what
else happened was poland taking over as
well what did the war game show russia
could do
well to run the counter-offensive to
take back the baltics
we had a
we had to come in through poland but we
had to fight our way back into uh into
europe because obviously we were at war
uh with russia and we're dealing with
attack submarines we're dealing with
cyber warfare in our country and we're
dealing with
a rival airfields and arrival ports that
were severely damaged by their uh air
campaign yeah so a significant challenge
we can't take this article 5
this paper agreement that we have for
granted it is about
boots on the ground
facing off and making certain
that putin understands there really is a
deterrent here that's what sends the
message not rhetoric yeah and in general
so then then there's this perhaps the
scariest aspect of it you talked about
it and that's what does china china see
what does china do
in this moment the chinese assistant
foreign minister is blaming the u.s for
russia's invasion he said the following
the u.s has been fueling the flames
fanning up the flames how do they want
to put out the fire
what what should we expect now from
china
well they're not endorsing or condemning
this russian invasion but believe me
privately they're cheering from the
sidelines because this place right into
president xi's narrative will i mean
you're familiar with it
and he's talking about the fact that
the united states and the west are
declining powers china is a a rising
power
the world order as we knew it is
changing and coming to their sphere of
influence in russia and china that is
what they're fundamentally about and
that is why
they have a relationship together they
have this significant historical
differences but they've come together
because they want to change the world
order and you see putin certainly making
taking a serious step in that direction
right now
and china i think the danger zone comes
after the national
party congress in the fall
when president xi will be enshrined
as the new leader likely with no term
limits
uh in 23 24 and 25 i think we're in the
danger zone where he will be
incentivized to do something about
taiwan in terms of using military force
and we have got to build an effective
deterrence that we do not have right now
in the indo-pacific region
general jack keane um concerning but
enlightening information this morning
always great to talk to you
yeah great talking to you will and the
team have a wonderful weekend thank you
you as well hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now